hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book three of on the ends Cicero has
Cato as the representative of the stoic
school set out some of the basics of
stoic ethical theory and one of the key
ideas that he brings up very early on
has to do with what we can call the
primary impulses or if you like drives
or orientations of human nature and
there's really two things going on here
in this discussion one is that the
epicurean representative in in the work
has already argued that every animal
from birth on desires pleasure and
avoids pain and so we can understand all
the things that we're doing in a sort of
developmental view as having that as
their underlying basis the Stoics like
many others reject this and they say no
there's something different going on we
have to have a alternate account of what
the primary driving forces of human
nature are and I would like to say from
the very beginning that you know sceeto
is not saying that this is is what
drives all human behavior in the
presence for developed human beings this
is the starting zuv it for babies and
children and then perhaps for many other
people who don't mature but as we do
mature new things get introduced that
that may stem from this but transform
the basis so it's important to
understand where we're starting from
from infancy on but that's not the
entire story being told so what is the
stoic view they're not using the term
wiki osis here which was a technical
term in stoic vocabulary but this is
indeed what is being discussed what
chaos is
means on a very basic level sort of a
becoming familiar or stemming from
familiarity with oneself with what is
within one's way coast what is familiar
what is part of who one is and they're
not again invoking that term but the
basic conception here is the same the
idea is that all animals everything that
is an immense everything that has
perception that has locomotion to
whatever degree animals do have a
certain basic set of impulses which
involve what we could call awareness of
self a little bit later in the
discussion Cicero is going to use the
term send some soui being conscious of
oneself being perceptive of oneself and
this doesn't necessarily have to mean
you know the proverbial navel gazing
very high level you know thinking about
one's own thinking or anything like that
know what he's saying and what this what
the Stoics maintain to be the case is
that every animal has some basic grasp
of its own reality of its own being
however dim that may be so what is this
involved he says the animal feels an
attachment to its own self it can be
framed in this way that that it has a
relation of valuing on a very basic
perhaps not even articulate level of its
own self what is what does this take
shape as then so we can think about this
in four ways the first two are that it
feels a kind of affection the the word
that's used there can be translated as
love or feel affection or even desired
Iligan ray and you really should
probably roll all of those in there
it feels affection towards what we can
translate as it's being some
translations have its constitution it's
it's framework what it is that makes it
what it is it's status in Latin so it's
not just the sheer act of being it's
being the kind of thing that it is so
for a baby being that wriggling thing
that has like little control over its
own limbs and is feeling all sorts of
things that it doesn't know how to
process that is it's it's status right
but also its relation to other things
and so it feels affection towards its
being it desires to to maintain that and
what preserves it or we could go a
little bit further and say what conduces
to it and of course we're a little baby
it doesn't know very much about this
it's learning it sort of by trial and
error by you know wedding itself and
then being you know dried off and
cleaned by being crying for food and
being given food and feeling a bit
better it doesn't have any sort of overt
conception of well if I take this food
in it's going to nourish me and then I'm
going to get you know bigger and
stronger or anything like that or if I
don't eat this food I'm going to die or
something along those lines but it has
some sort of inchoate basic conception
that this is something good for me and I
should take this in this is going to
help me this is conducing to preserving
my my BA so those are the first two
things it also has an orientation
towards you might say what is negative
so its orientation is that it feels and
again just translating rather loosely
here feels hostile the Latin word here
is here we go here that it's translated
feels an antipathy to those sorts of
things but the the Latin word is a lien
re if heels that those things are
enemies to it so antipathy works hostile
works any of those sorts of ID
what does it feel hostile towards well
towards its own destruction or damage
what is going to lessen it what is going
to reduce it to nothing it instinctively
feels hostile towards say you know baby
wets itself if it remains there in its
own filth it's going to eventually get
sick and it's going to hurt it more and
damage it and you know perhaps destroy
it in the end so it cries and says get
me out of here right and so that's
that's part of the way it works when it
feels hunger it doesn't know that it's
not going to die if it doesn't eat that
minute but a lot of babies perhaps we
don't really know what's going on in
their head in any explicit way perhaps
it has that sort of sense of things
going on so whatever is its own
destruction it's it's feeling itself
breaking down and whatever does that
whatever threatens that whatever
conduces to it it feels hostile towards
that so Cicero is saying that this is on
a very fundamental basic level and this
is what the Stoics actually did in fact
think about that so if that's the case
that means that pleasure and pain are
not actually primary the way the
Epicureans thought that they were so he
goes on and he says pleasure according
to most Stoics is not to be reckoned
among the primary objects of natural
impulse it's not pleasure that we're
actually desiring that's moving us it's
whatever is going to conduce to
preserving the being that we already
have an affection towards in being in in
health in robustness in power in however
you want to frame it and pleasure is a
mere side-effect of that it's not really
what's driving us so the baby nurses not
just because it's something pleasant or
because the baby says I'm going to get
pleasure this way but rather it nurses
because this is going to keep it alive
allow it to grow and then it happens to
get pleasure from that and it says this
is a nice addition to that so that's a
key idea now he also goes on and he says
there's other things that as human
beings we are distinctively attracted to
and this takes us beyond the level of
animality as such and into something
distinctively human what is that he says
we're attracted to truth and knowing you
might say we're attracted to reality we
are attracted to grasping reality as
such and we're also repulsed traumas
he's going to say the mistaking or non
grasping of reality so how does this
take form again we can see this with
little children once they've actually
mastered you know enough to provide them
with reliable locomotion and some object
constancy and to be able to you know get
out of the situations that they're
immediately placed in like being stuck
in a cradle or something like that
what a children do they wander around
tasting everything sticking their
fingers everywhere grabbing things
looking at them curious about things
this is why we have to actually keep
them from killing themselves when we're
babysitting them because they do want to
preserve their own being but they don't
know enough about the world to
successfully do that but why are they
out there looking at everything well
because they're they're curious they
want to know so he goes on and he says
acts of cognition and the word here is
just a transliteration of cognate
Sione's right knowing things together
you could say and he says we could also
call these and again just cognate from
from the English to the Latin comprehend
Sione's comprehensions percept Sione's
perceptions or he says if you want to
use the Greek term for it kotl ape says
this
is an important term in stoic
epistemology or stoic logic if you like
coddled apes ace means grasping the lam
bono the word that late States comes
from means to grip to grab to reach out
and get something and to cuddle ape you
know the cattle ape states of it kind of
kind of lates us in the singular is to
grasp it thoroughly and understand what
that thing is so this is something that
we do in fact desire and that motivates
us as well he also tells us something
quite interesting and you can see a
parallel here between the realm of
action and the realm of knowledge right
both in terms of affection how it is
that we feel about things he tells us
that mental assent to falsehood is
repugnant it's something that repulses
us that drives us away when we realize
that we've got things wrong unless we're
screwed up
we don't double down and say oh man I
know this is wrong but I'm going to keep
believing this anyway now we actually
feel a sort of disturbance when that
happens according to the Stoics and
according to such as the Stoics but many
other observers of human psychology so
this is something that is among the
primary impulses of human nature as well
and this leads us he says to you know
children having pleasure and finding
something out for themselves by the use
of reason even though they gain nothing
by it the sciences become things we
choose for their own sake partly because
there's in them something worthy of
choice partly because they contain acts
of cognition and contain an element of
fact established by methodical reasoning
we like to use our mental faculties just
like we like to use our bodies to do
things so these are things that are
fundamentally driving us and the last
thing I want to say about this is that
Cicero and the Stoics and Cato will
frame this in turn
of what is in accordance with nature
that's a phrase that you see the Stoics
using quite often you notice they're
beginning from natural impulses and
saying you can understand how human
beings develop from those natural
impulses and drives but then we go
beyond that this is not the end of the
story as we move towards wisdom and the
moral good or virtue we are going to go
beyond these mere impulses and the well
worked out sort of affections cognitions
and actions and choices that they
involve and that's going to lead us to a
higher phase of human development
you